Aloha rejects Greg Alba here I'm John
happy [ __ ] Halloween you [ __ ] let's
start off this Halloween day catching up
on some scary vids sort of semi scary
whatever Batman Gotham nightmare a lot
of people sent this in or it's kind of a
scary way of looking at bats
so I'm rocking my spider-man shirt
intentionally to piss off all the DC
fans DC fans are the easiest wants to
provoke what's up DC fans how your
feelings a little poked a little bit
nudge to the heart sickles a little bit
this is from the channel dark monolith
entertainment that sounds and as we're
watching this has 5500 views several
people sent this into our Facebook today
and I was like you know what I'm a big
fan of the bat sees nice good bumper
he's here
yeah cool that's the story he's not it's
a collection of a lot of movies she went
the symbol appears in several persons
having these dreams
so I love it
he's done awful thing to people and you
do awful things to you that was really
sweet
I was really cuz app when it first
started going I was I started thinking
like am I gonna have a hard time getting
past the collection of other movies yeah
but then as it progressed like absorbing
the concept was a lot easier to do and
the footage of you know a photo showing
it follows us or a quarantine yeah all
kinds of movies in here
well yeah it's almost like one of those
proof-of-concept videos that they yeah
at first I know sometime lot of studios
will like I heard the Hunger Games got
greenlit off of like taking footage from
all these other kinds of movies and then
putting a trailer together
yeah it's literally just going here's
what our movie would feel like here's
roughly how we'd shoot it and I want to
see this movie no I want to see that's a
great idea cuz those are always my
favorite Batman comics to the ones that
this sort of like trade graphic novels
that go into like weird or spookier
territory where like he's kind of crazy
and stuff there's a Batman cartoon
called it I think it's called Gotham
Knight where it is like five different
stories from the perspective of other
people so Batman is this mysterious
figure in Gotham City so we never see it
from like Bruce Wayne's perspective and
I we did a video a while ago called
comic book adaptations versus big-budget
movies where we were talking about how
we like to see like lower budget films
like when I see little over budget would
mean like 40 50 million dollar films so
it's not like too much yeah so yeah ones
that don't have to be so much about
spectacle and crazy action set-pieces
like I thought it'd be cool to do a
Batman you're one comic where Batman in
the comic II do see like Bruce Wayne and
stuff but I thought it'd be cool if you
like eliminated like soft primarily from
Gordon's perspective and all you saw was
Batman from his perspective and if he
saw Bruce Wayne the film never took will
never take the time to go Bruce Wayne
and Batman are the same even though we
know that kind of like the same thing
here like we know who Batman is we know
he's Bruce Wayne we know he's a good guy
but from the perspective of PEEP other
people he can be a
terrify figure that's the only in a
Batman if you only have that perspective
it creates a whole different dynamic for
that story that I wish we could explore
in a movie yeah it's like to make Batman
even to the people that Batman you know
saves and protects he's still got to be
kind of an imposing figure kind of yeah
a mysterious creepy thing that happens
to inhabit the city yeah you know I feel
like this kind of take on Batman would
have been perfect for Suicide Squad yeah
instead of what we got from the actual
release I think having like this kind of
respect I crime on Halloween many years
ago I had this like concept for like I
didn't call it Suicide Squad but my own
little fantasy dream project would be to
do a Batman story all from the
perspective of the villains where you do
see like Batman as the main villain but
they never you know but it's kind of
like this so seeing this kind of like
proof of concept put together was really
neat because it does show that you can
execute Batman by the end of it even
though you start I started becoming like
unaware of all the footage and I started
feeling the fear of like man that's
behind guys sounds pretty [ __ ] scary
actually
we had props too what do they call guys
you gotta check out it I want to check
out more dark monolith props to y'all
cuz like I gotta imagine it takes
forever to sift through all these
different clips to find out right stuff
and you know to find the right very well
edited takes from so many different
movies and have them not yeah yeah like
I was surprised too that I wasn't as
distracted as I thought it would be the
second I saw Ethan Hawke space because a
lot of these are horror movies yeah
so you know these are films that you're
very much more familiar like a lot of
these I'm always seen once you're a lot
of these are very familiar with yeah so
the fact that you were to yourself were
able to get past it was really good sign
up like some great editing you did man
yeah yeah you really put together a
thing that had its own tone which was
nice
good job happy Halloween all right
rejects if you're new to the channel
subscribe today and get accepted
sean is the social media manager of
facebook.com slash Blum house a lot of
horror [ __ ] on there and social media
manager of facebook.com slash the video
rejects
good amount of stuff there's here
Twitter and Instagram handle that
reasons to Gerry he does a lot there
I'm Greg I'm John he's a social media
mesh